JUSTIN JACKSON: You're not
going to get psychological depth
anywhere else in the
Hebrew Bible the way
in which you get it
here in the David story.
The David story confronts
us with those huge questions
of life itself.
What is man's
relationship to God?
What is man's relationship
to his fellow man?
What is a parent's
relationship to their children?
We understand all
of this when we
see David there with
the death of his child
and knowing he's fully
responsible for all of this.
It is the horror of each
one of his children.
David knows that it
always goes back to him.
Human beings will not always
do what we ought to do.
The solution is simple.
One repents.
I think this is what David
has learned, and, my goodness,
that's not a failure.
I would say that's precisely
what makes David a hero.
I would be delighted if you
would join me as we go through
and look at the David story
here to see the tragedy of Saul,
see how confused
a man that he is,
see both how obedient and
simultaneously disobedient he
is, to join me as we look
at David, a man who misuses
his kingship and then somehow,
even in the face of disaster,
he finds his way out of it.
He repents, and he
turns back to God.
And we'll be on that
floor with David
as he's weeping tears for a
child that's going to die.
And then in the stunning
moment when he finds out
that he's dead, he gets up,
and he can then be able to say,
he's not coming back to me.
Rather, I am going to him.
What does this mean?
And in what ways does this mark
out the rest of the disasters
of David's life?
What it will offer
to us is not a sense
of who David was historically.
I think it's supposed
to be asking us,
what are you as a human person?
I'm Justin Jackson, professor
of English at Hillsdale College.
This is our course
on the David story.
Let's begin.